[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOR NORBYE: I've
been asked all week
what it is I like about
Kotlin, and I basically
have to stop and say, how
much time do you have?
Because I could
go on for an hour,
and I have with some
people on the team until I
convinced them to
switch to Kotlin.
STEPHANIE SAAD-CUTHBERTSON:
A lot of us
started writing code
in Kotlin and found
it was just a beautiful
programming language.
It's so concise
and so expressive.
ANDREY BRESLAV: It's very hard
to pick a favorite feature,
because there are so many of
them, and I love them all.
But one of the most exciting,
and one of the first, actually,
that were thrown into the
design, is extension functions.
And we actually did
that the first time we
talked about Kotlin ever.
And it turns out to be a
very powerful and very useful
feature.
TOR NORBYE: I love the safety
that the language offers.
So null safety and
immutability are fantastic.
You can't get null
pointer exceptions
if you do things right.
STEPHANIE SAAD-CUTHBERTSON:
From today, you
can use Kotlin in
your production app,
and in fact it is being used
in production by Pinterest,
Square, and a wide range
of other apps, which
are major apps on Android.
ANDREY BRESLAV: In
terms of overhead,
calling Kotlin from the
Java language and back,
it's zero overhead,
because Kotlin compiles
to Java-compatible bytecode.
So it's the same representation
as what the Java language
compiler will give you.
TOR NORBYE: So one class
can call into Kotlin,
Kotlin can call
into Java, and so I
can do a very gradual
migration of the codebase.
STEPHANIE SAAD-CUTHBERTSON:
For developers who are invested
in the Java programming
language and in C++,
we are increasing our investment
in both of those languages
at the same time as we're
investing in Kotlin.
KATHRYN SHIH: It is now
fully tested and shipped
as one full bundle with Studio.
So if you like using Kotlin,
you don't have to do any setup.
You don't have to
do any worrying.
It will work out of
the box every time.
TOR NORBYE: My favorite
feature in the IDE for Kotlin
is the ability to
copy-paste code.
So I go into a Java
file, I copy the code
that I've written in Java,
and I paste it into Kotlin,
and it converts it for me.
In the beginning, that
was really invaluable.
I still find myself
using it a few times.
STEPHANIE SAAD-CUTHBERTSON:
When we talk to our developer
community, so many
people had literally
come out of the crowd, whether
it was in Reddit AMAs or events
that we went to.
People were asking
us for Kotlin.
KATHRYN SHIH: The community is
extremely excited about Kotlin.
We keep running into people
who can't stop telling us
about how happy they are.
MAXIM SHAFIROV: I would
like to say thank you
for those Kotliners who
were in the community
before this
announcement, because it
was tremendous trust
from those people
to actually use this new
programming language.
And this announcement
is only possible because
of those people.
So thank you.
And for newcomers, the long road
of having fun in programming
for you.
Let's enjoy it.
KATHRYN SHIH: There are
two sets of great resources
for learning more.
If you go to the Android or the
Android Studio documentation,
we have a bunch of stuff there.
And then Kotlinlang.org has some
really fabulous documentation
for learning the language.